معشوقته الا كمان علي بن عثمان كما قلنا
هو اول شاب تونسي وهو كان بصدد العزف
وسيواسل الان ان عزف على الهواء مباشره
علي بن عثمان كما قلنا تنقل بين عدتي وذا
افترس الموسيقى ثم تركها جميعا من اجل
ظروف خاصه لكنه وصل عشقه للموسيقى بالعازف
والعزف دائما سواء كان في الفضاءات العامه
الحفلات وكذلك في الشارع علي بامكانك
البدء بالعزف الان في المباشر والدخول
معنا مباشره من اجل الحوار بالفعل كما
قلنا الموسيقى الشارع هي ظاهره انطلقت
مؤخرا في شوارع تونس لكنها ظاهره تعاني
مجموعه من الصعوبات باعتبار وان ربما
الماره احيانا لا يتفاعلون بالطريقه
الكافيه خاصه على المستوى المادي علي
بامكانك الالتحاق باللان عليه لماذا اخترت
كمنجه لماذا الكمنجه التي تعتبر احد
الالات النبيله التي نراها في الصالونات
وفي الاماكن الفاخره لماذا اخترت الكمنجه
اي نوع بتاع موسيقى اي نوع من الهاوس من
الفرنسي هاوس ترانس
[موسيقى]
كل الاشكال الموسيقى
الوحيد تقريبا اليوم هل كان هذا الرهان
سهل بالنسبه لك ان تعيش على هذه المهنه ان
تكون هذه مهنتك الوحيده الاصليه
وثلاثه في كل مكان واحد تتعود على حاجه
باديهايه عندك انا بتاعته في الشارع وتنزل
تقابل جميعا مع انويه مع طبقات المجتمعيه
كله واحد وتشوف في العبيد شوف طبقات
الاجتماعيه لكل مع توينتي تاسف وتحسفه مع
تشجيع تحس فيما قلت انت ما ما يسمعوش برشا
وموزيكا عندهم همم مشاغل اخرى مشاغل يوميه
واحد وكل لما تيجي تنقل الموسيقى
ليس لديها امكانيات يعني نعرف ان هذه
خصوصيه لكن العاب المادي لهذه المهنه التي
تمارسها التي فيها الكثير من التضحيه لنقل
السيده المشاهدين انه هناك عوامل الطقس
هناك ظروف التنقل هناك ربما احيانا
الاستخدام بالمره الذين يكونون
تعتبر وان التضحيه التي تمارسها تاتي
اكلها اليوم
بصراحه حقيقيه
بالدينار التونسي و البطاقه الشرائيه
التونسيه اينا اييه فوريك زمبل دخل مدخولي
مع 80 دينار يوميه هي نجمه نقول
شو اسمه
ولا 90 دينار
خاصه
التي تفكر في العوده لدراسه الموسيقى 2010
موسيقى في شوارع تونس التي على مر هذا
العقد من الزمن ما زالت هناك اصوات الماره
والمواطنين والمطالبات بالاصلاحات
والمضيء نحو الاستقرار في هذا البلد